let's go to our voicemail number that
number is two one nine two david p i got
a very fair question there there's a I
say it like I'm surprised I got an
unusually fair question in the voicemail
today let's take a listen to it hey
David I just have a quick question here
so I was just wondering if things and
Republican policy issues that you
support I understand that a lot of the
issues that the Republicans have been
you know campaigning on I've been the
water failed policies and a pretty
aggressive and I just wonder if there's
at least like wanted to hold the issue
of the Republican Party that is that it
did get internet there cuts off right
there Wow okay
I understand the question where do I
agree with Republicans and quite frankly
the answer is areas that I agree with
Republicans are pretty uncontroversial
and Democrats are sort of on the same
page you might say well David you've
come out against toxic identity politics
that's something you agree with
Republicans on not really because
Republicans drastically overstate the
issue of toxic identity politics I'm
sort of with the sensible left on the
fact that identity matters and we should
listen to voices that have a identity
characteristics that make them tied to
certain issues in particular ways but I
don't actually think that the issue is
as big as Republicans say so
so like even on that I think I agree
with the sensible left I've talked about
how I do agree with Donald Trump's tax
plan in one sense which is that it
lowers the threshold at which point
medical expenses become deductible but
that's not really a big policy position
of the right it's something that they
threw into this particular bill so I
don't know I mean am I am I missing an
area Pat where where I agree with
Republicans over the left or are there
anywhere you agree with Republicans over
the left the only disagreements that can
think of that I have with the left has
to do with the fringe left so I'm
thinking of like GMO the dangers of
GMO the anti-vaxxers community tends to
be on the left really just French stuff
the anti-vaxxer community is an
interesting one because it exists on the
right for religious reasons and on the
left for reasons of distrust of
corporations so that that's that is an
interesting one but yeah I agree I
disagree with the fringe left on
vaccines and and with the fringe right I
can't think of anything else but I'll
give it some thought please take the
David Pakman show audience survey we've
got it up for just a couple more days
it'll take you 90 seconds david
pakman.com slash survey and please
become a member become a patron support
media that matters to you if we whatever
the results today are and i hope you
will be a part well whether you vote or
not you're a part of the results because
not voting is not neutral but i hope
you're a part of good outcomes today we
are going to have a very very steep
uphill battle for the next couple of
years and i would love to have your
financial support through membership or
through patreon and one of the things
you would get if you were such a
supporter is access to the bonus show
which starts in just a couple of minutes